rodriguez last time i was against the
yankees and of course uh again in that
ball game five and a third no decision
the e rod gave up five hits and three
earned runs did have seven strikeouts to
start previous to that was only four and
two thirds against the houston astros
down in houston gave up six earned runs
so first base run of the ball game
brings up alex breckman looking to go
four straight change ups and cut on and
miss to put him away you don't see that
every day no you don't and bregman
looked like he hadn't seen it every day
either
kind of look he came out to erod after
that last one another perfect change a
perfect location and you can see again
how off-balance bregman was and he
stands out there like okay
four in a row alvarez 299 eight home
runs he's driven in 31. correa the base
runner
big swing popped up on the infield
devroos has to make a little change
there almost none of the base runner
correa but he puts it away for out
number three in the red sox you're
coming up no score
zach greinke is on the mound for the
houston astros how about his last four
starts 203 era a
.077 as far as whips are concerned doing
a very good job eight plus innings in
three of those four starts zach hasn't
faced the red sox very often in fact
first time in an astros uniform
swinging a miss the back goes flying as
grenky picks up a strikeout of [ __ ]
hernandez for the first half here's alex
ferdugo missed the first couple of games
of this series with a strained back
little tapping ground ball towards
correa and the ship carlos makes the
play plenty of time to get verdugo and
there's two outs 2-2
swing and a miss cranky with a couple of
strikeouts in the first inning only had
three strikeouts in his complete game
against the blue jays scoreless first
well here's the guy that now leads the
american league in batting yuli guriel
coming in at 3 35. he passed vladimir
guerrero jr last night here it comes
sends that one down the right field line
giving it a look is
the right fielder hunter
and that is off the foul pole for a home
run pesky pole power for la pina do it
tk that's a lot of happy guys in the
dugout knowing that's a birthday gift
courtesy of fenway park one day late are
the fans booing yuli or are they booing
the pesky pole the friendly confines on
the road have been anywhere the
ashevilles have been but right now yuli
taking advantage of the circumstances
hitting it off the pesky pole oh that's
going to be rich on statcasts estimated
315 feet and i feel like that is too
much
azkaz batting 249 on the year astros
have the infield back they'll concede a
run to try and turn two here
he does go to right field for a base hit
and that'll tie up the ball game
so debra's in the score that's three
consecutive hits off of zach reinke so
enrique hernandez will be up with the
bases loaded all loaded up runners go
3-2 pitch
and it is outside he walked him and a
run is in
a renfrow will score and the red sox
lead it 2-1
yordon hits one to deep center field
back goes hernandez he will watch it
bounce off the fence and stays rattles
around out there one run scores here
comes bregman trying to score they'll
cross the plate two rbi double for
jordan alvarez and the astros regain the
lead it's three to two
martinez to lead it off in the bottom of
the third three two astros
he's gonna hit a high fly ball center
field deep straw is back he's already
looking and that ball's gone home run
well it has been a while and jd touches
them all to tie the game 3-3
his 13th of the season oh is that good
to see with the game tied here's vasquez
royal on deck in the 2-1
socked into center field down for base
hit
sandra bogart is kind of marching home
and the red sox have the lead against
the astros 4-3
vasquez off to a great start tonight
[Applause]
outside ball four astros will load up
the bases with yuli guriel do up and
alex cora as soon as that pitch was
called the ball jumped out of the dugout
way outside ball four game tied bases
loaded walk to yuli guriel
both teams have a bases loaded walk for
an rbi tonight
as straw crosses the plate it's four to
four
that ball into center field well struck
all the way back hernandez near the wall
it's off the wall one run scores around
comes alvarez he'll score julie guriel
behind him he'll score kyle tucker to
third clears the bases with a triple
it's 7-4 astros
loop that one into right field for a
base set
denver's rounding he's heading for third
and vasquez has another single to right
bill he's three for three yeah two to
right field tonight one to center field
to one
swing a high fly ball
deep left center back it goes and gone
three run shot for arroyo
he jumped all over and he's tied the
ball game let's get another look yes a
spinner that stayed on the inside corner
and he just yanks it out of the ballpark
a long way out
altuve golf's one deep to left field all
the way back towards the monster good
jose altuve
home run number 11 gives the astros an
eight to seven lead
how does he do that
four
he took that off the ground blubber
brings up jd martinez who blasted that
home run in the third
high pop not deep
tucker coming in
[ __ ] back to tag and he drops it and
here comes the run
he is safely in and the red sox have
tied the game
on a drop by tucker
popped up in the center
correa out
and staggers and drops it
martinez had to wait
and they're going to get the out
on the infield fly is that what they're
calling here
take another look
right up here now a sludge watch the
umpire does he call him phil fly
we can't see him right there but he does
he's pointing to devas yes and saying
you're wrong
and the old one that's inside and it hit
him it hit him and that's going to force
him to go ahead run oh no i've seen
everything
payoff pitch runners go and he walked
him and here comes another run
[Applause]
that one ripped toward the wall and left
field and slams into the monster
one run in here comes basquez in down to
second is dolbeck and the red sox give
themselves some big time breathing room
[Music]
right before the season
newly fouls one off his foot
i think they called him out i think they
said that ball was in play that's gonna
end up being a double play what
the umpire pointed towards fair
territory
home plate umpire
[Applause]
a yorn on
who went down to second
thought there was a dead ball as did we
we thought that was fouled off of yuli
at the plate
but
sean barber just tossed dusty baker
he claims the ball was in fair territory
red sox are on top 12-8
into center field closing out at
hernandez and a diving catch
sort of been the one thing it's been
lacking right to this point an
outfielder making a diving cast
here comes the o2
swing fly ball center field it's deep
backing up hernandez room to make it
he's got it
and the red sox win it 12-8